it's January eighteenth 1919 and with din of World
War one finale still ringing in his ears Woodrow
Wilson arrives in France for peace conference
at Versailles General Pershing greets him
and here's Lloyd George of England big boys
and gathering of 70 delegates of 27
nations assembled in Hall of Mirrors
the palace of Nations nears completion
so that those who believe the peoples
of the world can live together may have a
home where they can plan and work together
and here arriving at conference hotel
quarters is Wellington ku for China and
delegate from Poland is famed pianist
premier Paderewski with Paul Heyman's
first president initial meeting is
success as delegates bow for Fisher
Barnes and Lord Cecil lead many in voicing
opinion that lead will keep world at peace
but in 1931 League of Nations deals
with first of series of disasters in
the Far East Japanese soldiers launched
their Manchurian invasion overrunning
Chinese strongholds and blasting
Chinese cities into submission
China appeals to the lead for help and
in fall of 1932 League delegates visit
battlegrounds in disputed territory then October
2nd report to leave that Japan is fully at fault
but Matsuoka Japan's leading delegate at Geneva
States his country does not agree with ruling and
Japan not only refuses to abide by league's
decision but walks out of the assembly look
at the faces around the retiring Japanese do
they reveal what's coming the judge odd face
of this man foretells the future and defiance
of League orders benito mussolini calls for
italian conquest of Ethiopia and return of
Italy to the gold and glory of empire then
one Adolf Schickel Gruber leaves Germany's Nazi
Party under swastika symbols and the phony name
of Adolf Hitler and defies the League of
Nations once again now three great nations
have defied the Assembly's power and this is
what becomes of the gallant League of Nations
but out of the ashes of hopes that are
destroyed new ones arise in shadow of
San Francisco's Golden Gate with Wilson's
dreams of 1919 world leaders of 1945 form
the United Nations old League of Nations power
is handed to new generation now names are not
Wilson George your clemenceau but Stettinius and
Truman of the United States and there's hope that
history will not this time repeat itself but
will improve by the failures past weakness
wounded the League of Nations that conflict
killed but their strength in the United Nations